what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and
I've got a guest with me tell them who
you are man hey it's Danny from geek
10101 how are you rob I'm doing pretty
good man let's talk about cartoons and
was in explosions um alright so so I
made a video recently where it was like
ultra instant Goku vs. Herald of
Galactus Hulk and I started thinking and
I was like I should do a video with
Danny where we just we we asked the
question can can anybody in the Marvel
Universe stand against the character of
Jared from Dragon Ball super
who as I understand it right now correct
me if I'm wrong Danny as I stand
understanding right now he's like I
think the most powerful character we've
seen so far he's the most powerful
character outside of the gods he's the
most powerful mortal now his backstory
has not been revealed yet as of this
recording so we don't know if maybe he
was a former god there's lots of
different theories out there but as of
right now they're keeping him a mystery
he's pretty much a plot device he's
pretty much just a big strong super hero
from another universe and that's
literally all we know I think he I think
his power comes from power scaling like
yeah we're fans go to forums and they're
like I want my favorite hero to win so
I'm gonna cook the books so they win
like I feel like like a curatorial and
then we're just like how do we take that
idea and put it in the form of a
character and then they call him
cheering like he's just a big muscular
he's what every comic book fan loves a
big muscular badass who just tears
people apart and and doesn't even break
a sweat doing it we have not seen this
man yet at full power so his abilities
could be quite scary in fact when he
first powered up he shook the entire
void he shook the entire world of void
to the point where even the gods of
destruction all the gods were in shock
that a mortal could be that powerful I
mean they really built that up they've
never built up a character this much
since Frieza back in like 1990 oh I know
that's the crazy thing because I think
they're like when when Goku first met
him like he teleported behind Goku did
me and Goku was just like what like it
was kind of nuts um no I'm I think it's
I think it's cool I mean because
honestly seeing somebody like Joran pop
up and people are just like mark look at
the power he has it does remind me of
the first time Goku went super saiyan
here's Rob you know however old I was 13
14 years old I remember but like Goku
turns into a Super Saiyan for the first
time
and like I remember reading about it
online all the time you know like all
the synopses like window who becomes a
super saint and then seeing it happen
it's just like all dude all dudes about
to get crazy you know and things that
started popping off it was it was so
exciting to see and so it kind of brings
me back to when I was younger right and
the thing about this character is they
took that same feeling and they kind of
doubled it and tripled it I mean we know
we've talked in the past about Super
Saiyan God and how in the anime version
of goku vs beerus they're punching each
other and as they're punching each other
they're cracking the fabric of the
universe the entire universe is shaking
and there are stars and plants being
destroyed during that fight when goku
use Super Saiyan God against jiren which
again this has now been two and a half
or so years after that first beerus
fight i think two and a half or three
years i remember exactly how long it's
been
shiron blocked it with one finger he
used his index finger to block a punch
that had the ability to shake an entire
universe so we're talking about a dude
who is unfathomably strong not to
mention that he didn't break a sweat
during the fight Goku is hitting him
with Super Saiyan shots didn't even
bruise or even a paper cut and then Goku
used the genki-dama the Spirit Bomb with
all the energy of all the participants
including the ones that were eliminated
and jiren reversed it on him with one
hand I mean like that was a crazy thing
like like when Goku gets like ultra
instinct I was like dude this is crazy
so many great memories so much high and
the rematch is coming they are gonna be
doing that at some point in this arc I
will say this though as far as scaling
where he ranks in the in the hierarchy
of power you know obviously we have the
Omni King at the top he can destroy a
universe with a blink of an eye in fact
he destroyed the multiverse and Trunks
art by himself then we have the Grand
Prix strapped below him the father of
the Angels and then we have the angels
and they do have reality warping
abilities the angels can reverse time
for three minutes they can create matter
out of nothing they can build like it
built the entire arena they can create
metals and things like that just you
know and some of the other gods have
that ability but the angel seemed to do
it a lot more flawlessly plus it's
implied that the Angels have all at
least we sim batos have mastered we got
to know Goku e the Ultra instant power
they've
whereas Goku just tapped into it but
when it comes to like outside of those
characters it is stated that jiren is
more powerful than 'god destruction they
don't specify which one but in the manga
they say he's stronger than vermouth
which is his gob destructs from universe
11 they don't say he's stronger than
beerus but it's hard to argue
considering that he blocked Super Saiyan
God Goku punches with one finger and
again this is years of training so that
version of God Goku is way stronger than
the one we saw in battle of God so I do
believe you put a gun to my head I'm
gonna say he's surpassed beerus well no
I gotta believe that cuz I'd have to
believe that all the gods of destruction
even though some might be stronger than
others did I imagine the difference
between their strength level isn't that
wide like I clean yeah I don't think
you'd have like beers who would just
dominate all the other gods of
destruction I have a hard time kind of
leaving that so if durin is more
powerful than like his god of
destruction then he's either equal to or
more powerful than all the gods of
destruction I mean to me it just makes
sense I mean I'm not gonna swear that as
gospel truth and please don't take it
that way guys I know some of you will
I will say that when Goku first got
ultra instant beerus looked kind of
frustrated because the whole thing about
that power the mastery of self movement
is that it's not even easy for gods to
attain which tells me that only a
handful of them even know anything about
it but he did it and beerus looked very
frustrated almost like he was concerned
that Goku was closing that barrier
between them ok so correct me if I'm
wrong wasn't least like the first one to
like master that and then he was also
using a number judean Goku when he was
training him he was the first one that
we saw in the series mastery he was
teaching Goku and Vegeta in the
resurrection F movie in arc the secret
of selflessness which is the mastery of
stuff which is it's all based on like
jeet kune do-- and bruce lee and
historian was a big Bruce Lee fanboy
yeah he was teaching them that the
secret to being a great martial artist
is to allow your body to work on
instinct not on memory but it takes
years of training and so on and so forth
that being said he was trying to teach
Goku em but you know that all the way
back in that arc and now in this arc
were finally seeing the realization of
it in fact when they released the teaser
poster says something to the effect of
the work of the gods is complete and it
showed Goku an ultra instinct we didn't
know what that meant back then but now I
know yeah that's crazy because it's kind
of nuts cuz Goku these powers always
follow like this sort of linear path
like there's this huge fight you know
like with Frieza or cell or you know
majin buu or something like that and
there's like a scuffle and then he's
like ok what did I learn and then like
the scuffle ends and then like there's
another scuffle and you know when the
scuffle ends it's like ok what did I
learn but like with ultra instinct it's
just like you kind of intuitively reacts
to what it is they're doing so we
thought of like having to focus on their
counter-attacks and watch what they're
doing he's just like all es to do is
focus on what they're doing and like
that I imagine that allows him to pick
up like subtleties that he wouldn't
normally be able to get under a regular
circumstance you what I mean yeah and
it's interesting because when Goku is in
that form his eyes are silver and it's
implied that he's in a zombified state
because after he loses the power of
ultra instinct Vegeta asked him he's
like hey what was that and he doesn't
even remember so it's almost like he
goes into a trance where his body just
moves by itself obviously the way I
think the story's gonna go is that
eventually Goku will learn how to
actually tap into it at will and that
will be hopefully his final form because
I think in my opinion there's too many
transformations his damn show already I
think this should be it yeah
well it also begs the question where do
you go from there like I mean when it
when it's like higher levels of power
and it's like all these different stages
of Super Saiyan it's like okay look
that's cool that makes sense because
it's just a higher level of power to
defeat a foe but then you start getting
anything
like ultra instinct Super Saiyan
actually that sounds pretty awesome when
you think about it like a Super Saiyan
form of ultra instinct that could be the
next level hey maybe they gotta sell
toys bro Dragon Ball super is a toy
seller I'm just saying like imagine how
Goku looks with ultra instinct with like
Super Saiyan 3 length hair that would be
pretty boss arts already out there man
oh I guarantee it is yeah I could
imagine this like it's crazy okay so
anyway guys so on sheer strength alone
like speed accuracy you know just like
energy strength like jiren among the
mortals is the most powerful we've seen
so far and so that begs the question if
we took the character of Jaron and we
threw him in the Marvel Universe how
would we fare but in order to make sure
this this conversation doesn't go off
the rails we're gonna provide some rules
the first thing we're doing is removing
reality warping and that's like the only
rule we're gonna have cause like if
molecule man was the person that jiren
had to face molecule man can turn
anything into anything he controls
reality he's like a multiversal threat
like Franklin Richards right yeah
exactly so they'd face off like during
which is show up we like I'm gonna
destroy you and they're like no you're
not they turn him into a teacup and just
smash it I mean you know it was like
okay well I guess that's the end of year
I mean that would be boring so Braddock
grabbed characters and we're gonna say
okay like the strongest characters in
Marvel Comics and there's a little
there's there's actually quite a few of
them but to me I would argue this the
absolute strongest person in Marvel at
least as far as I'm aware that ever
existed it's probably try on juggernaut
if we remove reality warping characters
and characters with insane levels of
telepathy or telekinesis or whatever
then like try on juggernaut is probably
the most powerful now do you know the
story of Tryon juggernaut tell me I know
that you said he was more powerful than
World War ho yeah right correct yeah
like he's he's on a whole nother level
from World War Hulk so back in the 90s
and I can't read it I want to say there
was a story where juggernaut like lost
his crimson gem or something along those
lines I don't member but the whole idea
was that he had basically traveled to
like Korea or something along those
lines because there was rumor of a
second crimson gem and so when he went
to grab it he was basically tricked by
this crazy cult and he lost his powers
so maybe he didn't lose the first Jim I
don't never anyway he ended up being
imbued with like a second Jim and the
whole idea was he was basically imbued
with like the full power of Sid Iraq and
Sid Iraq is one of these entities that
exists out there that's crazy he just
has his own dimension called the Crimson
dimension to give a perspective of house
city rack is he once confined Galactus
and Galactus couldn't escape that is
absolute peak and as soon as he became
like Tryon juggernaut he punched a hole
through like this dimension like he
started punching reality itself which is
an insane display of power like being
able to break down the walls of reality
just by sheer force just by punching it
it's crazy but he's just imbued with the
power of an entity now while CID Iraq
can do things like warp reality the
juggernaut didn't do that it was just
sheer strength on a level that we've
never seen before cuz that's one of the
reasons why I kind of posed him as a
character and I think he's really the
only legitimate character I mean I can't
imagine anybody else out there I mean
wow as far as I know I mean unless
you're gonna go into god territory you
know and talking about you know the lady
death and cares like that I wouldn't
think so either
now what's interesting though from the
Dragon Ball perspective is that in the
blue arc majin buu was able to scream at
the top of his lungs and unleash his
power and crack a hole in the
dimensional fabric so that sounds very
similar to what we're talking about here
with you know try on juggernaut cuz you
know boo did it and actually vegeto not
even this is before super saiyan blue
before super was able to punch through
him cracking the universe's fabric
either the dimensional fabric that is so
I feel like that's been done even back
in Zeke kinda sort of it wasn't a punch
but it was a screen I imagined it still
kind of stands - the same thing though
it's the same thing by two different
means you're breaking down the walls of
reality just by virtue of your actions
yeah and here's the thing if that
happened all the way at the end of Z
we're now significantly and super
significantly more powerful than end of
Z characters I kind of a mattering to
sidetrack for a second I think it'd be
funny like you could go back and you
watched like the end of jagan Ball Z and
like Goku and Vegeta are just like
struggling against majin buu
imagine if Jaron was there yeah it
would've been all she wrote but it would
have been funny yeah I don't know I mean
you don't see very many characters and
Marvel that can basically destroy you
know the fabric of reality or punch a
hole through the fabric of reality
through sheer force I mean a lot of
people who do that like warp reality you
know they use their crazy powers in
order to pull that off and so I can't
feel like just by sheer strength alone
like jiren probably would be able to
dominate the Marvel Universe but that
begs the question what if like a cosmic
entity put all their power into strength
like the living
bah demon of the universe eternity was
like okay so like I am going to use all
my power and I'm only going to apply to
my physical strength and fought Gian
so if goku and beerus were able to
affect the universe by virtue of their
punches jiren being that much higher
like where do you think that battle
would stand no I think if a Marvel
cosmic being put all of their power into
strength
Garen would be history because I think
people underestimate how powerful these
cosmic beings are like eternity is like
beyond that God it's like sort of a
representation of existence I don't even
know how to even describe it like a
principality I remember when I was a kid
looking at my Marvel Comics trading
cards when I was super into it and I
remember just just being in all of this
like this idea of the in-betweener like
this idea of this physical
representation of matter so I do believe
I think that that would be able to knock
off jiren because that's just used too
much power I mean we've all like like
bow maintaining balance of existence
it's hard to comprehend those kind of
thing you know it is and normally I
would agree with you but if Goku and
beer is fought on such a scale that
their impacts were able to affect the
physical structure of the universe and
that power paled in comparison to the
power that cheerin had I think it
presents a pretty legitimate case that
like if the universe got up in the form
of Eternia if they could get up and walk
around and it was eternity and it
channeled the power of the universe into
a punch and hit jiren while it may like
injure him I don't think it would kill
him like I think he would probably live
it's it's hard to say because when
you're doing these kind of thing about
jiren to is that he's also super fast
you know the only way to keep up with
Geron as far as speed goes is with ultra
instinct and when go who was doing ultra
instinct Jaron was actually for a second
there for just a split second he was
challenged so we're talking about an
incredible amount of speed but I just
feel like if you have a being that
represents the universe that is like the
embodiment of the universe the universe
has no beginning or end as far as we
know of course in theory the universes
is eternity it's endless so I just feel
like something that's endless is faster
than light if that makes sense but I
don't know I mean that's the I don't
know it is a weird constantly I know
it's a weird question to ask but like
that stuff's so fascinating to me
because I mean the universe has a finite
star point and a finite end point we
know the universe will end I mean that's
what oblivion I think it is that's what
he represents is the time but
the universe ending in the universe
beginning so like the universe will go
away which means it has a finite level
the power of the universe is whatever
power all the Suns and everything but
even eternity as a being can be
destroyed I mean we've seen that happen
like yes a being a fictitious strength
can destroy eternity but you're talking
about you know like like matter
manipulation but even then that's that's
why power scaling is so weird man
because if God is hunched in such a way
that it can potentially fracture the
universe and jiren can easily withstand
that that kind of physical force then I
have a hard time believing like the
universe would be able to like kill
jairam I don't know is it that's just
kind of how it comes across to me well
it's tough because you know we also got
talk about the spirit bomb the
genki-dama
in that goku is using energy not just
from his friends but also energy from
himself and if goku has that kind of
power inside of him - like we talked
about cracked the universe or whatever
against beerus then that spirit bomb
that genki-dama had to contain at least
a portion of that power and jaren
blocked it with one hand
you know effortlessly it seemed you know
and then goku try to send it back to him
that little volleyball thing but it just
wasn't enough and that of course with
goku using all of his power to stop
himself from dying is what triggered the
ultra instinct power from a tap into it
so it's just interesting to me because
you make a very very good point in that
it wasn't just the punches him he
blocked that was impressive he also
nerfed kaio-ken blue times 20
you take the god power of crack in the
universe you add the blue multiplier
which we don't even know what it is
necessarily but it is more powerful it's
been confirmed then you add times 20 to
that so it's like times 20 of the
ability to crack a universe then you can
crack 20 universes crack the multiverse
right so I you know what like at the end
of the day you kind of have convinced me
too that there's a possibility cheering
can win it's just so hard to up to
understand like an entire universe being
put into one person but you're right
like you know we've seen the gods be
destroyed we've seen objects in the
Marvel Universe that can do things like
that you know it's tough to say though
like I can't really give you a straight
answer and I hate to cop out like that
one more thing I want to point out we
haven't even seen jeering at full power
yet because yeah the thing about the
tournament they disabled the buku jutsu
the grand priests is so powerful he can
actually disable techniques in disable
specific kinds of energy from being used
so you cannot
why in the arena even if you try to the
grand priest has deleted the move it's
weird to think about but he has and yet
we see jeer and they're meditating and
floating he is floating so his power may
supersede not necessarily the grand
priests far as combat ability but he can
at least supersede the ability to delete
the book of jutsu which to me is like
yeah you know what maybe he will be a
turn I don't know I mean okay you know
what I think what make it easier like
okay because I think it was in Dragon
Ball GT which gemology T's suck and I
guess we can't really use that anymore
but we're going to sorry about your luck
guys but I feel like in what was a
Dragon Ball GT I remember if it was the
the evil dragon saga or which one it was
but he made like a universal spirit bomb
and like through to the dragon and it
didn't it didn't necessarily stop if we
had that in Dragon Ball super which I
wouldn't be surprised if that's what it
took in this final battle between Goku
and jeer and like when they get their
final match she's just like alright I'm
gonna make a spirit bomb out of all the
energy of the beings who exist here and
like all the universes and throw it at
jiren and see what happens that would be
pretty nuts but even then like I would
imagine the power he used in the spirit
bomb against year and probably
supersedes a universal spirit bomb I
think so but also it's gonna be goku
can't even do that now because they're
fighting in the world of void and
there's not that much explanation but
the world of void exists outside of the
multiverse Zeno and and the world of
void are not part of the 12 universe
it's like a separate dimension outside
of those universes and there's also
dimensions inside the universes so it's
all crazy
but if Goku were to gather up energy I
don't believe he would be able to get it
from outside of the world of void now I
could be wrong on that we haven't seen
him do it but at this point I think
they're just gonna go with the ultra
instinct Goku vs year and fight now back
to your GT question the one thing about
GT the owl was find interesting is that
the last dragon he thought which was
omega shenron yishun long in the
japanese version he has enough power his
negative energy he's composed of pure
negative energy is so strong that it
could actually see through into other
universes and other forms of reality
like the gods even said once he consumes
the earth and the universe were next
like the in other words heaven like the
heavenly realm is next so that to me I
always felt was interesting because even
in GT you had characters that would do
stuff that's just ridiculous but I do
believe in super they've gone past that
it's hard to say cuz they're two
different branches of canon you've got
the GT continuity and the super
continuity but if you were to combine
them it's tough to say if jiren can
block a multiversal if he--if Goku's
never done a genki-dama from 12
universes that's that's a lot for me oh
it's gonna happen though
you better believe it's gonna happen I
made the prediction at the beginning of
the series as a joke it might actually
happen whether it whether it's in GT or
whether it's actually in the Dragon Ball
Z that leads into Super it's been like a
stage thing but he's made a head
everything he made a spirit bomb out of
the people on earth and then he made a
spirit bomb out of the people on Namek
it's increasingly gotten bigger I mean I
could see him just I mean if he made a
spirit bomb out of the people who were
like in the void then I can see him
being like well there's only one thing
left personal spirit bomb like throw it
adjourn yeah I don't know if that would
be enough the only time we've ever seen
a character wipe out a multi versus a
gnome so that's that's that is the
highest scale we've seen in Super so far
and I still believe that there is a
higher God because we've only seen Zeno
the Omni King destroy we've never seen
him create and I believe there has to be
a God whether it be Toriyama or not I
don't know but there has to be a god
like the Jack Kirby joke about him being
the one above all there has to be a God
that created the multiverse and they
haven't revealed that is yet yeah I mean
it makes sense if something destroys
somebody has to create kind of like a
yin and yang so like that what that
would make sense to me okay so yeah I
mean I guess just based on sheer
physical strength I don't think there's
anybody out there who can defeat urine
being able to break through dimensional
barriers has been done
Goku embarrass you know basically did
that and they're fine at least they were
cracking the fabric like the walls of
the universe so like that that's
something that like that they can do
presumably if they'd fought long enough
that's something they could do so that
knocks out try on juggernaut as a
possible candidate and then when you
start looking at anybody who's lower
than try on juggernaut
aside from folks who can warp reality
like nobody else with physical strength
could probably pull it off and then
grabbing like cosmic entities if they
channeled durability into strength that
was kind of hard to gauge because if you
have a character like Dormammu for
example like Doctor Strange made the
case once that if to her mom whoever
entered the main Marvel Universe feat
like nobody would be able to stop him
but like what if he just channeled I was
an entry into a punch what do you still
be able to defeat urine but there's
always gonna say that's you one morphine
and even get into so this is the
scariest feat jaren's ever had I haven't
even thought the host Avia for the end
when he fought hit he
used a a well I believe it's called a
time vacuum because hick can use time
skip and what happened was hit trapped
cheering in a time vacuum in other words
he trapped him in endless time and jiren
broke out of it and vato said and I
quote his abilities are more powerful
than time itself we have never seen a
character like that I even mixed I love
your height man all your hype is amazing
yeah if the guy can defy the laws of
time it's too much for me you're getting
at a comic book territory man like
Marvel and DC Comics stuff I didn't even
mention that because I was saving it for
the end here but yeah that's ridiculous
he broke out of a time vacuum yeah I
mean okay so for those of you guys who
are watching this who were who were
strictly coming from like the Dragon
Ball stuff like what you guys are seeing
with this that's old hat to us in comics
like we're used to that like it's stuff
that we've seen forever and at all
honesty I think the idea of having too
many reality warper kind of drags down
the nature of comics which is one of the
reasons why I always liked the idea that
Dragon Ball just focused on hey a person
with all this power but it's only
confined to like how hard they can punch
and like how fast they can move and how
much energy they can project because
it's a massive amount of power
this limited into like three or four
different you know practical uses
whereas like if you if you go and look
at Marvel like during a Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers these
beyonders beings from beyond the
multiverse showed up and they destroy
the Living Tribunal basically this judge
of the multiverse when the Living
Tribunal died a fraction of himself
basically fell in every universe that
ever existed like it's crazy just you
know when you look at that kind of like
abstract concept
why is when they kill Lady Death and
nobody could die yeah that was uh what
was that the Thanos Thanos imperative
where they killed mistress death and an
alternate reality and it just filled
with life like it was easy yes crazy
yeah yeah it was nuts no I mean that's
this I mean I know it's power scaling
and I'm not the biggest fan of power
scaling but that's the only way to make
a legitimate argument like that if jiren
can easily withstand a spear bomb
compose of the most powerful beings and
the multiverse Dead or Alive
and if jiren can basically break out of
the constraints of time itself
and if jiren can easily you know block
the punch of a person who could
conceivably punch reality or that least
the impact of its punches can basically
fracture
I cannot imagine anyone in the Marvel
Universe that would stand a chance
against your I mean I guess maybe if we
invoked like the one above all or like
the Living Tribunal I guess sure or like
superpowerful reality-warping so you can
just Rema t realize him but even then
it's not a guarantee because you're
talking about a being with a level of
power that's so astronomically high that
it's almost unconceivable but you also
got the hack characters like I would
think that Professor X might be able to
crack his brain yeah I mean yeah I guess
a telepathic character could probably do
that but I don't know I mean like okay
so so the whole idea of ultra instinct
hits at the idea that is basically
autopilot like go cruise body just and
you know instinctively reacts which at
that point it's not even about the mind
it's about what the spirit of the body
does because that's been the whole idea
of Dragon Ball is you know being a good
fighter is a combination of just like
strength and spirit as opposed to like
you know how smart you are but if it
comes down to that level you know if
here at Orianna and then finally like
give us like an origins episode more or
less we're it's like the origin of G
Rand which will be like the most-watched
episode of Dragon Ball ever then I feel
like they would basically say like
between his meditation and everything
you've seen so far he's a beer a being
of like pure energy you know or like he
exists on a spiritual level that's so
astronomically high people can't
challenge it and even at that point it's
not a matter of the mind I mean I guess
you could you know you'd have to get him
when he wasn't when he wasn't fighting
right yeah I mean I would I would think
so but and I mean even then like if you
remove the strength factor in reality
warping power there's other characters
who are out there like jason wyngarde
he's basically got really weak character
no way he would stand a chance against
urine in physical fighting but
mastermind has the ability to basically
manipulate the five senses everything
see touch smell taste and hear all
becomes reality if he wants it to be and
so I guess you could just trapped urine
in that kind of a situation but I
imagine if Jaron realizes what's going
on he was just pretty out of it so I
don't know it's clearly a level of power
that we've never seen before in any of
the Dragonball Canon so it's kind of
crazy
no again it's one of those things where
when he cracked time I didn't even know
how to take that like it's just I did
think about comics and I thought about
just like you said earlier in this in
this thing where they go from here yeah
yeah where do you go with a character
that that incredibly powerful I mean I
don't know I feel like you were just
plateau because at that point when you
have a character that's that's that
insanely strong did you just kind of get
into levels of silliness
what about the Beyonder like how do you
feel about him again stuff well like I
said I mean at that point you're talking
about an incredible
level of power I mean you're talking
about like reality-warping the Beyonder
was back when in Secret Wars - he was I
think right below the one above all he
was so powerful that like the Living
Tribunal and all the cosmic entities
went to the molecule man Owen Reese and
said you have to fight this guy like we
can't be a hint we've got nothing on it
I mean you weren't talking about an
insane level of power but again I think
with characters like that it's it's
really more reality-warping than
anything else I mean I guess with that
much power they could punch Durin's but
even then I mean like I said jiren is is
easily able to withstand the punch of a
person who's whose impact of their
punches can fracture reality so I don't
know I mean now I get to be different if
Goku would just like punched reality and
broke it you know and then Gian was
easily able to overcome that because
then that creates a far more
quantifiable thing but you know it's
really just kind of conjecture at that
point when it's like well they kind of
they could have fractured reality if it
had gone on long enough but I mean
that's what they said that's what they
said it said they've go Quinn beerus
that kept going it would have put the
entire universe in danger yeah pretty
much but I'm curious like leave a
comment cuz I want to know what you guys
think of me I know there's a lot a lot
of like jiren fans out there and I know
there's a lot of people who were just
like I hate your and he's a plot device
he's ruin a Dragon Ball so let me know
down in the comments cuz I'm kind of
curious and yeah make sure you guys
check out Danny over a geek m101 you
have anything you want to say to him
thanks a lot for having me check me out
geek them 101 and I want to do this
again sometimes a lot of fun yeah dude
this was pretty amazing this is cool I
mean it's a great way to kill half an
hour so and people love stuff like this
it's kind of crazy there's no definitive
answers the people are just like I just
want to see what people think I want to
see if they agree with me so they're
gonna fight about it forever
they are I mean the comments section is
just gonna be filled with so much our
viewing anyway guys we're gonna go ahead
and ring this video to an end like I
said go check out geek them make sure
you guys go check out his channel pretty
solidly it's where I go to get all my
stuff about Dragon Ball so make sure you
guys go check them out and yeah we will
catch you all later peace oh really
I cut you off I having no peace
[Laughter]
[Music]